Latin America is struggling to stop the
corona virus from spreading and it has
the potential for repeated outbreaks
that could reach the United States
Brazil's president has been criticized
for dismissing the threat his country
reports more than 25,000 cases but
researchers believe the real number
could be more than 10 times higher
Manuel Bojorquez shows us how people in
Latin America are forced to fight the
virus on their own and we should warn
you some of the images in this package
are graphic protecting Brazil's poorest
neighborhoods is too often a
do-it-yourself project locals fumigate
on their own makers of carnival costumes
so medical scrubs iconic beaches sit
empty as Christ the Redeemer pays homage
to medics but even as cases spiked the
country's autocratic president choi el
bolson otto continues to mock the
virus's threat posting on youtube cheery
appearances at donut shops and
glad-handing with supporters just two
countries over Ecuador's largest city
Guayaquil is facing a very brutal
reality nearly 2,000 bodies have
reportedly been collected for burial
some in cardboard caskets many were left
in the streets for days this is a
generational event dr. luis Yepez told
me from Guayaquil his largest hospital
we've never lived through an emergency
like this I think the biggest problem is
that when social distancing was
requested people didn't take it as
seriously as they should have he said
many found it impossible says Alexandre
moncada
director of the organization care in
Ecuador people cannot afford to stay in
their houses if they have no income she
says Latin America's severe inequalities
poor social safety net and fragile
infrastructure were all laid bare in
Guayaquil
a warning for the region as the virus
spreads if our governors don't provide
the example and have clear messages and
that the population should stick to it's
more difficult to ensure a rapid
overcome of the situation
Manuel Bojorquez CBS News